- Oh my gosh! You guys look! They have
Cornhole, we have to play! Yes!
This is the best game ever!
Good morning.
- Hey what's up, how are you?
- I am having a fight with
my sister right now it's,
oh my god and the
traffic getting here this
morning was too much,
did you experience that?
How are you?
- I'm good.
- Mmm. Do you have any
ranch? Do we have any ranch?
Oh, excuse me, could
I get a side of ranch?
Alright, so we're almost to the
expressway, I mean, the freeway.
Aw, you know what we
should do this weekend?
- What?
- We should go the lake.
- You mean the beach?
- No.
My friend has a boat, we
should totally go the lake.
- And do what?
- Just hang out.
(dramatic music)
I need to use the restroom.
- Do you want me to order you anything if
the waitress comes?
- Sure, I'll have a pop.
- What?
- Oh, uh, a coke.
- Oh my god it's cold. Are you
- Do you ready to go?
- Uh, yeah. (laughs)
Padiddle! (hits top of car)
- What is that?
- Puppy chow, try some.
- Okay.
That's very good, I will
take that, thank you.
- Hi. Hey how are you? Hi! (laughs)
(cheerful music)